THEY WANT WHERE MILLS FAKES LIKE
HE'S GOING TO SET A SCREEN,
SPRINTS OUT AND HE WILL SHOOT A
THREE-POINT SHOT.
>> Chris: STEPHENSON FOR THREE.
>> Quinn: HE STRUMZ HIS GUITAR
RIGHT AWAY.
>> Chris: HAD NOT MADE A THREE
IN HIS PREVIOUS TWO GAMES.
>> Quinn: HE'S COMING DOWN.
THE DEFENSE DIDN'T GET TO HIM.
THAT'S WHAT THE PEOPLE REMEMBER
FROM HIS PREVIOUS TWO STINTS.
HE WILL STRUM THE GUITAR IF HE
DOES SOMETHING WELL.
>> Chris: FIRST THREE OF THE
YEAR.
FOR LANCE STEPHENSON.
PLAYED SIX GAMES IN ATLANTA ON A
10-DAY HARDSHIP CONTRACT.
WHEN THAT EXPIRED HE SIGNED A
10-DAY HARDSHIP CONTRACT WITH
THE PACERS.
THE TEAM THAT DRAFTED HIM BACK
IN 2010.
A PRODUCT OF LINCOLN HIGH SCHOOL
IN BROOKLYN, NEW YORK, LAST
NIGHT PLAYED HIS 300TH GAME IN A
PACERS UNIFORM AT MADISON SQUARE
GARDEN AND IRONICALLY HIS FIRST
GAME BACK IS AGAINST HIS HOME
TOWN TEAM.
A
THREE-POINT SHOT.
>> Chris: STEPHENSON FOR THREE.
>> Chris:ER